[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, second Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merrick is in the office of Lord Jamis, having been summoned to his office.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is sometime around 3 p.m.
[SPEAKER_00]: He enters the office and sees a strange man sitting on a chair in front of Lord Jamis's
[SPEAKER_00]: Not the kind of character Lord Jamis would normally have in his house.
[SPEAKER_00]: Kind of a rough looking guy.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've never seen him.
[SPEAKER_00]: No, he's...
[SPEAKER_00]: He doesn't look... too soft.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he's a sailor, obviously.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's armed.
[SPEAKER_00]: With a bow and a sword.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he looks very fresh-faced.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: And do I know why this meeting's happening?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Jamis had one of his runners come and get you from FURDS earlier this morning.
[SPEAKER_02]: So what's this meeting about?
[SPEAKER_02]: You ask him?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, I ask Jamis.
[SPEAKER_02]: Jamis is not there.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, he's not?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: What are you doing here?
[SPEAKER_01]: I was sending my Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_02]: Who are you?
[SPEAKER_02]: A friend, the hand of Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Interesting.
[SPEAKER_01]: I usually know, you know, close friends to Jamis, so I never heard... Jamis walks in.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no close friends.
[SPEAKER_00]: You should know that by now, Merrick.
[SPEAKER_00]: He sits down behind the desk.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have associates and I have enemies.
[SPEAKER_00]: I counted your father among my friends.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, with his death, I have very little that I wish to speak to.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge, however, I would talk to about certain things.
[SPEAKER_00]: He knows the way of things.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, Davis.
[SPEAKER_00]: I summits you both here for a reason.
[SPEAKER_00]: As you know, the city has been in dire straits lately.
[SPEAKER_00]: This war with Keoland...
[SPEAKER_00]: And it's gone badly for us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Last night, another bad turn occurred.
[SPEAKER_02]: Getting worse.
[SPEAKER_00]: Closer, even.
[SPEAKER_00]: We did not lose these ships.
[SPEAKER_00]: A fog engulfed Helm Island last night.
[SPEAKER_00]: A strange fog.
[SPEAKER_00]: Very strange for this time of year.
[SPEAKER_00]: Normally the winds would have bloated away and the ocean would not have been warm enough to create that.
[SPEAKER_00]: When it lifted, we signaled Helm's Island like we always do after a storm or occurrence when we lose contact.
[SPEAKER_00]: The signal we received back was not appropriately coded.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hmm.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've just come up from a meeting with Prince Jeon and he thinks that I'm a little too alarmed, but he's willing to send a Cossaire out that direction to get in contact with Lord Fairwind, who is currently running the garrison on Helm's Island.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did any of our troops do any inspection or anything?
[SPEAKER_00]: You are the first unit I'm going to be sending out there to do the inspection.
[SPEAKER_01]: Am I right or no?
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll give you guys a minute.
[SPEAKER_01]: You want something to drink, though?
[SPEAKER_01]: Give us a minute, T-Bone.
[SPEAKER_01]: Anybody want anything to drink?
[SPEAKER_01]: There's all kinds of mishmash in there.
[SPEAKER_01]: White Claws, Boneyard.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'll put that.
[SPEAKER_01]: Is that cider?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, it's an IPA.
[SPEAKER_01]: I like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: How do I turn this down?
[SPEAKER_02]: Counter-clockwise.
[SPEAKER_02]: That turns it off.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do I turn everything off?
[SPEAKER_02]: You want everything off?
[SPEAKER_02]: No, not really.
[SPEAKER_02]: No, the other way.
[SPEAKER_02]: Counter.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, there we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: That'll fire back up.
[SPEAKER_01]: So I was the first to know, alerted to this.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, you must have
[SPEAKER_02]: Greater than just intuition or suspicion.
[SPEAKER_02]: If you're calling me to go out there, you obviously have him and a crew could go inspect and get the proper coding.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have talked to Lord Jamis about my suspicions.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, he...
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince John?
[SPEAKER_00]: Prince John about my suspicions.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, he has rejected them, unfortunately.
[SPEAKER_00]: I personally think that Lord Fairwind is a traitor to the other princes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've talked to you about my concerns regarding the Toli, the Prince of Toli, Saknad Toli, and how he has been acting towards us lately.
[SPEAKER_00]: I believe that Lord Fairwind is feeling this way as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: He made many demands in Privy Council last month.
[SPEAKER_00]: Specifically regarding more money from the trade that comes into Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's been bad blood between him and Jeon for years now.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm worried that he is working with Toli in some way.
[SPEAKER_01]: Have I noticed anything suspicious during controls around Helm Island in my last few weeks?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, everything seemed completely fine to you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Now, you don't go into the council room with Lord Fairwind and talk to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's way too high for that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you haven't seen anything like...
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, Sahaugin tracks on the beach or anything like that.
[SPEAKER_02]: No rumors amongst the crews and the people.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, the rumors among the crews are very, very interesting to you in that they are basically like, why aren't we going out there and kicking the shit out of the Keogh Navy?
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, we could easily destroy these guys if we wanted to.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's holding us back?
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's where the stories of supernatural occurrences and the strange storms
[SPEAKER_00]: have occurred that have put the Monmurgian fleet and the Outer Island fleet at disadvantages during very strategic times.
[SPEAKER_00]: And there have been a couple of ships that have been lost even though they should have easily have won in battle.
[SPEAKER_00]: The survivors of those ships, and there have been a few that have been collected, basically told of fog and
[SPEAKER_00]: A large ship coming out of the mist.
[SPEAKER_00]: A ghost ship that was like one of the Toli slavers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Huge ships that are 300 feet long that would crash into the Cossairs and destroy them.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then disappear, not being seen.
[SPEAKER_02]: So upon these rumors, this is the first confirmed of like a strange fog that has happened, that there's been rumors of different stuff, but this is...
[SPEAKER_00]: The fact that it happened this close to Monmurg makes me think that the news is closing around us.
[SPEAKER_00]: I don't know if this is the Toli, even though you've had interactions with their agents, this Lord Front, or if this is a ploy by Keoland itself.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is Kane Toli doing these things, Gouge?
[SPEAKER_00]: I have no idea.
[SPEAKER_00]: To be truthful, at this moment in time, I do not care.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sending you, with the Kosair, to be my eyes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to know how the captain does his job, and if there's anything strange regarding the island itself.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sending you for another reason.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to know if Lord Fairwind is a traitor, and if he is, I want you to do what you do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Get to the bottom of this.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll have an ally on the boat.
[SPEAKER_00]: You will be disguised, however, as a crosswoman in the unit.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're not going to be able to wear that armor that you have on.
[SPEAKER_00]: I have some studded leather for you in the back.
[SPEAKER_00]: You must disguise yourself, Gouge.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fine.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jude will be on the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do not speak with him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's easy.
[SPEAKER_00]: He will be in the presence and accompanying a young princeling named Paul Rivero.
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul Rivero is Prince Jeon's nephew.
[SPEAKER_00]: No harm should come to him.
[SPEAKER_00]: I argued against
[SPEAKER_00]: Paul Rivero going on this mission, but Jeon wants him there as his eyes.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's trying to give the boy more gravitas.
[SPEAKER_02]: You're not going as far as saying that I've got to watch out for him.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's Jude's job.
[SPEAKER_02]: Perfect.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, if Paul dies, it will reflect badly on you and my eyes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Help Jude if needed.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's all I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_02]: You up to this task?
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, if one Ferris put me on it, then we'll let it be sold.
[SPEAKER_00]: Merrick, I know it's going to be difficult to trust Gouge from the get-go here, but he is a very loyal man to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Trust his judgment, especially when it comes to battle.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you trusted my father, Jamis,
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't challenge your judgment.
[SPEAKER_00]: Good.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please support his authority if required with the troops, but only if it is absolutely necessary should you expose yourself.
[SPEAKER_00]: What I would rather you do is be able to infiltrate the helm
[SPEAKER_00]: Become close to Lord Fairwind as a troop, trooper, and see what is going on.
[SPEAKER_00]: It could be that I am just paranoid and everything is fine out there.
[SPEAKER_00]: However, the fact that they are not signaling back correctly worries me greatly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, strained fog, strained ships,
[SPEAKER_02]: Not signaling closer.
[SPEAKER_02]: I would obviously respect your judgment more than the prince's.
[SPEAKER_00]: His mind is not as suspicious as mine.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sure rightfully so.
[SPEAKER_00]: And unfortunately I think that there have been infiltrations into the royal palace as of late.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you know from what direction the fog blew in from?
[SPEAKER_00]: This is the strange thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: It didn't blow in from anywhere.
[SPEAKER_00]: It just occurred.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, nothing like I would have ever seen before.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, very magical to my mind.
[SPEAKER_00]: As if summoned from nowhere.
[SPEAKER_02]: On my previous expedition there with the wizard, do I know if he would have been powerful enough for a level of something this kind?
[SPEAKER_00]: You didn't get the...
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, to be honest with you, as you saw him battle, Jude's better.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean...
[SPEAKER_00]: He, you know, Lord Frog was not like a slouch or anything like that, but when he was fighting these Toli guys, he'd be casting the spell, and it's as if the Toli assassins, who seemed to have some magic of their own, would slap his hands down.
[SPEAKER_00]: Like he'd be casting, and they'd be like 30 feet away and just slap his hands down, and he wouldn't be going, what's going on?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: He wasn't like...
[SPEAKER_02]: He wasn't all-powerful.
[SPEAKER_00]: But he could do fireball, he did lightning bolt.
[SPEAKER_00]: It was not like he was just completely ineffectual.
[SPEAKER_01]: So is he coming onto this trip as disguised as someone under my brigade or troops?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or am I just more of an advisor on the trip, kind of watching out and seeing what's going on under the captains?
[SPEAKER_00]: He'll be a replacement under your command, as it were.
[SPEAKER_00]: A cross woman.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a unit.
[SPEAKER_00]: The ship, the Cossaire, is going to have 250 Marines on it.
[SPEAKER_00]: You'll be able to integrate without a problem with me.
[SPEAKER_01]: So are you okay with me giving orders with knowing your mission intent, knowing what must be done?
[SPEAKER_00]: Merrick, you will have no authority.
[SPEAKER_00]: There will be a marine captain there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You will be there as my advisor.
[SPEAKER_00]: He'll know who you are, so he will definitely ask your opinion.
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, this is not my show.
[SPEAKER_00]: Understandable.
[SPEAKER_00]: Makes it easier for me.
[SPEAKER_02]: I gotta do what I gotta do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Excellent.
[SPEAKER_02]: Hey, we're all here.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so... Are you willing to change out of your dragon armor and let Lord Jamis take it?
[SPEAKER_02]: Am I willing?
[SPEAKER_00]: Begrudgingly, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you change into the studded armor.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I'm going to say if you're taking it, just at least have it cleaned.
[SPEAKER_02]: He laughs at you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm surprised you'd let me touch it.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, don't try it on.
[SPEAKER_02]: Won't fit.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll have it cleaned if you promise to take a bath.
[SPEAKER_02]: Well, I'll see what the wenches can do.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anything else you need from me, Jamis?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just keep your eyes open.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to know if there's anything strange that has occurred around Helm Island.
[SPEAKER_00]: Look for signs.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll say no more.
[SPEAKER_00]: Just use your powers of observation to make sure that
[SPEAKER_00]: Everything is as it should be.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know Helm Island as well as anyone.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've walked the coastline.
[SPEAKER_00]: You've seen the signs there.
[SPEAKER_00]: Make sure there's nothing strange there.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's what I wish from you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm afraid there is more influence.
[SPEAKER_00]: If it's just Fairwind, that's one thing.
[SPEAKER_00]: We can deal with him that way.
[SPEAKER_00]: If there's something else occurring, something associated with the Toli, I wish to know that as well.
[SPEAKER_01]: Keep my eyes and ears open.
[SPEAKER_01]: What are we going to call him if he's going to be under disguise for the ship?
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll let him pick a name, or you can pick a name for him now you wish.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's your backstory.
[SPEAKER_02]: Aristotle is my name.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's going way back.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes, that is going way back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, sounds good.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, meet the ship.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's leaving in 20 minutes.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's out at the Royal Docks.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know the way.
[SPEAKER_02]: We've got to stop by the tavern before we go.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll only need five minutes there, but I'll be at the dock.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay, so you go directly to the dock.
[SPEAKER_02]: And you've got something to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm going to go pick up a couple flasks.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So you go to the bar, and actually there's one right outside Jamis' place.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sure I know them all well.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know them all well, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is out on the Harbor District.
[SPEAKER_02]: So you go down and... Two flasks of red eye, put it on my tab, I'm in a hurry.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, the two of you walk down to the Royal Docks.
[SPEAKER_00]: You see a coser that's in the process of being loaded with Marines, like a battalion of Marines, ready for battle.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's not like this is just nobody doing anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's like Jamis has convinced Jeon not to just send a small mail ship out there to do what they're about to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: All right.